good afternoon everyone i'm priyana
tarajan an astrophysicist and faculty in
the departments of astronomy and physics
at yale
i also serve as the current director of
the frankie program in science and the
humanities the flagship
interdisciplinary program at yale that
catalyzes intellectual exchange and
collaboration across academic
disciplines
i am delighted to invite you all to the
monthly convening of our nature of
inference colloquium series
first i would like to start by
recognizing the generosity of mr and mrs
richard and barbara frankie whose
support of this program and many others
at yale have vastly enriched
intellectual engagement and innovative
scholarship
then i would like to remind you all that
as we are recording this event um that
all participant videos and microphones
will remain muted uh please go ahead and
submit any questions you might have
through the q a feature uh dr ty camp
and i will be managing the q a at the
end of today's talk so i am delighted to
welcome today's speaker
partly because he is one of our own
distinguished member of our own faculty
dr nishi vishnui
and before i tell you more about his um
you know various honors accomplishments
and so on i have to add that one of the
particular pleasures of having one's own
colleague um speak
is when you have someone like nishi who
is so incredibly intellectually curious
um that it is going to be an utter treat
i promise you all to hear him speak
today
so as you all know in this wonderful
series we've been exploring how we know
what we know in terms of generating new
knowledge in a range of disciplines that
study varied phenomena be protein
folding and structure and its
implications and impact on how our body
functions or how we build models of
complex physical systems like climate
and make predictions
today speaker dr nishit vishnui is going
to talk to us about perhaps one of the
most complex systems that we encounter
how we individually and collectively
make sense of the world the ways in
which we model the world in order to do
so and the limits of therefore what we
know
delving more deeply into the profound
questions
of where many of these limits of what we
can know and what we do know arise from
it is a real pleasure to have
one of our own faculty members a
distinguished member of our faculty
dr vishnoi talked to us today about bias
in algorithms
so to give you a sense of the breadth of
interests
and the range of wonderful original
scholarship that nishith has been
engaging in let me tell you a little bit
more about him so he is the bartlett
giamatti professor of computer science
and the co-founder of the computation
and society initiative at yale he
studies the foundation of computation
and his research spans
multiple areas in uh theoretical
computer science optimization and
machine learning he's also interested in
understanding the nature and society
from a computational point of view
his current focus includes studying
entropy
the range is going to be astounding
the emergence of intelligence behavior
and ethical problems at the interface of
artificial intelligence and society
he has many many honors and i have
cherry-picked a few so that i don't keep
you from listening to him
for much longer he was the recipient of
the best paper award at the ieee
symposium on foundations of computer
science in 2005 the ibm research pat
goldberg memorial award in 2006 the
indian national science academy young
scientists award in 2011
and the iit bombay young alumni
achievers award in 2016
and you know multiple best paper awards
at various conferences the one that is
relevant to our talk today is at the acm
conference on fairness accountability
and transparency in 2019 he was named an
acm fellow in 2019 and his most recent
book algorithms for convex optimization
was published by cambridge university
press
and as this customary with this
colloquium series it'll be followed with
a conversation with another
distinguished
practitioner who brings a slightly
different perspective so following uh
professor vishnoy's talk today we will
have the conversation on monday with
professor alexander madri uh who will
lead the post talk discussion um
on monday monday evening so without
further ado let me um turn the floor
over to nishit nishi we are delighted
you are here and are really looking
forward to hearing you
thank you priya for that very generous
introduction and thank you all for being
here uh good afternoon good evening
wherever you might be
uh so if it's okay i'm gonna share my
screen yeah yeah please go ahead
so the the topic of the talk today uh is
bias in algorithms
and
my plan is to give the
listeners
a sense of
how in this very objective world of
algorithms
which live in this uh very precise
mathematical framework
uh
human-like qualities like bias
can emerge
and what can we do
to
intervene and mitigate these algorithmic
biases
and
in the process of trying to figure out
the
ways in which we can mitigate these
biases in the world of algorithms we
will also see at the end how we can gain
some insight
about
a mitigating bias in the world of humans
itself
so
um
let me start by setting up the framework
in which the world in which we live in
so it's not a
it's not news to anybody here that
humans live in an algorithmic world let
me make this a little bit more precise
humans
us
in as a society are consuming
a huge amount of information uh
through various online channels uh
unlike you know the old world you know a
few years ago where we were looking at
newspapers and so on now everybody gets
their news through twitter facebook or
equivalent
we connect with people
uh through these social applications
which are
uh made possible through this world wide
web or internet
um
we are also increasingly using
algorithms in the context of governance
policy and so on
and last but not the least many of the
utilities that we consume today
from ride sharing apps to
online shopping platforms
are all governed by
decision making algorithms which are
constantly learning about human
preferences
through the data that they generate
and
presenting information often in a
personalized manner to these individuals
and this in this information is
affecting who we are as individuals and
giving
shape to the society uh in a very
different way and at a very different
scale than we imagined previously
so this is the context uh that i'm going
to be talking about
and let me say a few words about
algorithms
and i'm going to focus on artificial
algorithms
which
largely developed uh you know
the formal study of algorithms in the
discipline of computer science is about
you know i would say
a bit less than 100 years old starting
with the works of turing and others
who started looking at algorithms or
formalizing the notion of algorithm
and
in the last few decades we have come a
very long way
in designing artificial algorithms
which have shown the ability to mimic
some of the most complex natural
algorithms
for instance priya had mentioned protein
folding i mean one of the most recent
successes of artificial algorithms is
the ability to predict the tertiary
structure of proteins
which has been one of the main
challenges
not to mention beating the best players
in the most complex games
predicting
weather you know and i guess the more
relevant algorithms that we are going to
talk about a little bit today are things
like you know algorithms used in courts
and by judges which decide who goes you
know who gets bill and who doesn't get
bail or
artificial algorithms which are
deciding who gets loan and who doesn't
get loan and so on so there is a vast
and complex landscape of algorithms
um
very very roughly
you can think about
an artificial algorithm as
in in today's world as something which
has a few components uh not necessarily
all of them but
there may be some data available from
which the algorithm might want to learn
to learn something we need to have
a model we need to figure out figure out
you know what in you know what is
allowed
for us to learn uh i mean when we are
trying to
learn from data what are we allowed to
use in that learning process and that's
the step that i'm calling the
statistical reasoning model
and finally once you have decided on the
model
and you have the data you might you will
need an algorithm
which can then find the best model
from this data and we're going to talk a
little bit more about in detail so this
is just a very high level view
for you to get a sense of
what many of these algorithms look like
and
the point that i would like to highlight
is that
um
these decisions that we see here right
from data to to selection of model
selection of training algorithm to
selection of anything involves humans
and so
this is why we call call it i mean
artificially intelligent algorithms
because you know humans are making these
decisions
one thing that remains common
uh no matter which artificial algorithm
you look at is that they live in a very
precise
world which is governed by
unambiguous mathematical rules
and
[Music]
and you know somehow people in society
associates objectivity to mathematics
and
uh we can we can we can go into that at
some other point but there is some
association of objectivity to
to to to do the mathematical precision
and so there was some expectation from
these algorithms that they should also
be objective
and not show human-like qualities
unfortunately
this was
uh this is not true and i guess this is
not news to anybody here nevertheless i
will still go through some examples
um
i would say about uh less than a decade
ago
many researchers started auditing
algorithms which are being used in very
very broad settings for instance search
so you go on something like google and
search for google images
and search for something like a ceo
and you know it's not like google just
has these 15 images of ceo that has
billions of images probably which attack
ceo
and then based on what it understands of
you
and
the word ceo it will pull out a small
uh subset of images for you to see
and this this this process of i mean why
small because your screen is small your
attention is small so you can't really
process billion images
uh and perhaps that's not what you're
looking for so
uh this process
requires solving an algorithmic problem
of selecting a subset for a particular
individual
to
to view
and presumably there are some objectives
i mean why is
you know
the search is for free so there is
clearly some objective of showing
these images to you and
and one reasonable uh objective that
many of these
uh companies have is
to maximize engagement so so we keep
giving you
good results so that you keep spending
time on our platform so that we can keep
showing you ads and so that you can go
buy products right so
um more strikingly and i mean you know i
guess
less strikingly and more strikingly at
the same time
um some very
uh
you know so facial recognition has been
you know very important in this whole
fight against algorithmic bias and their
uh interesting and important work of uh
joy blooming intimidate gabriel uh
showed that off-the-shelf classifiers
manufactured by
some of the most standard and
well-trusted companies such as ibm
showed remarkable
uh differences in the ability to
classify
people based on their
protected attributes such as race and
gender
um and since i talked about showing
advertisements you know showing
advertisement is in the core business of
many of these platforms
and
there also there were biases i mean it's
not surprising but it was observed
that women get shown
ads for
low-paying jobs while men get shown more
ads for high-paying jobs
so okay so you know as a as as somebody
who who might have not seen this before
or whose skeptics say okay you know this
is what is being shown what is the
problem with this
you know somebody can
anybody can show whatever uh they want
to use so what is the issue the issue is
that the output of these same algorithms
can alter human perceptions
okay so it's not like just seeing has no
impact on us seeing is believing in this
case
and
the same studies which found these
biases also found
that
people who may or may not have an
opinion about gender bias or gender and
ceos after being shown
images which are distorted or
representations which are distorted
uh have distorted perceptions of what it
means to be a ceo
and i guess
we have all gone through this
phase and no matter which country you
live in where we are seeing
increasing distortion or increasing
divergence without saying what is right
what is wrong our world views are
diverging or polarizing
so
uh polarization has had a destructive
effect on democracy
it has given people the ability to
manipulate elections and so on so there
is a lot of stuff to read about here
and
this is
these are the core issues that i'm going
to address in this in this
talk
but even before i go there
i want to first address the question of
anatomy how does
bias emerge and to understand that
we have to understand a little bit in
more detail what i showed in my first
slide
um
how
do we learn what is this uh you know
what what is going on in this algorithms
so this is not a mathematical talk uh so
unfortunately i will not be able to show
you a lot of equations in other venues i
would
but
hopefully i'll give you uh some
concrete idea more concrete
than in the first slide so that you know
you go back with a very graphic sense of
how
these algorithms operate
so the starting point is the real world
right so this is the world in which we
live in
and
when we talk about data
data doesn't live in the real world data
is collected from the real world
and to collect data you first need to
figure out how to represent it
so i'm a person
uh if some organization let's say the
u.s government wants to collect data
from me
they will specify
uh that you need your first name last
name age this you know social
whatever they'll give me a template and
i need to fill out
most situations i really do not have an
option so i need to fill out all this
data and give it to them
so two two points here one is
representation which is that i i have in
most cases i i would be given some kind
of a form it could be electronic it
could be a physical form where i fill
out information
it could be somebody taking pictures
right so i need to add a picture which
is also very specifically specified uh
in in certain cases
and then
certain individuals are
selected for such data collection so if
you are doing let's say a survey or
trying to estimate something about a
population it's infeasible
to collect data from everybody so you
will select some
uh
subsample now to what extent the
subsample is good is is uh is
is often not clear
so so data has these two major
components there are other other bells
and whistles but
in the in the first order understanding
of things this is what it is
now that you have a collection of data
you want to learn from this data
and learning happens in
a hypothesis class so the more complex
the hypothesis class the the more
you have the ability to learn
and most learning algorithms will fix a
hypothesis class
and
um
and these uh
and these then determine
uh i mean these these hypotheses are
parameterized
so
and not i mean it will not be the case
that one hypothesis will explain the
data so there may be many many
hypotheses which explain the data
so then comes the question of which one
to choose
so which is the best
hypothesis that will explain the data so
we have to fix a mathematical notion of
accuracy or something
which helps us select
from this white class of hypothesis the
one which is the best
once you have made these choices we go
on to find the most accurate model
and
and using something called the training
algorithm
and that gives rise to the
the
the decision-making algorithm
which then is used in the real world so
maybe this algorithm will be used to
decide who to give loan or who not to
give loan
and that has a direct social impact
whoever gets loan their life changes and
whoever doesn't get along their life
uh probably worsens
i mean given the fact that they're
looking for a loan
so this creates this feedback loop i
mean these output of these algorithms
could also feed into other algorithms
and and so on and so forth
so the design choices are human choices
they are driven by human motivation so
each step of this process there are
humans who are deciding
and their decisions are motivated by uh
what they think is valuable
so the real question is you know who
decides
who do who does this benefit and who is
harmed and all of these questions are
very important i mean and
these questions are generally not asked
in the design of algorithms
because whoever is designing the
algorithm it's their benefits
that
certainly are incorporated very very
rarely are there's a discussion on who
could be potentially harmed and what can
we do to mitigate those hearts
so in all of this
algorithms end up being brittle
and
gain the ability to encode human biases
so so at this point i guess uh it should
be uh it should be i mean the point that
i want to make is that
um
well one more point i want to make is
that
uh you know one of the reasons why this
study on algorithmic bias got really
uh caught the attention of media i mean
that's really where
it got into
is because in the end what does it show
it shows and it gives definitive proof
that humans are biased
if i catch somebody and say hey you're
biased
they may say they may argue and wriggle
out their you know way through that
discussion and in the end no nothing
conclusive came out but if the same
person hands me an algorithm which i can
keep repeating again and again i mean
keep running it again and again without
any further intervention once the
algorithm is there that's it and then
you can say look i mean if you are not
biased and how can this algorithm be uh
biased so it gives us a definitive proof
now without pointing fingers it gives us
a definitive proof that humans
are extremely biased
and that's what these algorithms are
picking up
so it gave us a lens into our own uh
existence
and
and it should not be surprising that
while studying or as a bigger goal of
studying algorithmic bias is to try to
understand various ways in which humans
can be biased and design
frameworks and policies to mitigate
those biases and i'll come to that
towards the end of the talk
so um just a little bit more
uh uh just a little bit more graphic uh
image of what goes on
uh if i take a simple example let's say
of
who to give loan uh
or not let's say the society consists of
you know this is a very toy
caricaturization of the problem this is
not how it works but it will give you a
sense of mathematical sense of what goes
on
so there are people some people let's
say are women and some people are men i
understand that things are non-binary
but for this uh this thing
uh let's just just consider that
and traditionally
uh there has been disparity because of
the construction of various social and
political systems
uh
men and women in our society are not
equal unfortunately
and suppose we choose features
corresponding to women so suppose i pick
two features
features meaning what about the
individual do i need to decide whether
to give someone a loan or not
so let's say as a bank manager i decide
i'm going to ask to encode
to the extent to which the person is
educated and the income
so let's say these are the two
coordinates here that you see two
numbers associated to each person some
mathematical encoding of their highest
educational degree in this case is five
and some mathematical encoding of
of in this case it's 10. this could be
10 000. this could be 10 million but
yeah without going
assigning units to it i just think of
them abstract exactly
and then many of these algorithms also
need uh
some kind of uh
you know
historic data so in the historic data i
would probably also need
to know whether this kind of a person
ended up repaying their loan or not this
use this information is useful for me
but i don't want to give loan to people
who are not going to pay back to me
and and then you know when i i talked
about models so models could be as
simple as selecting lines straight lines
to to to divide the data into positive
and negative examples so this
so plus means positive examples and
minus means negative examples so i'm
looking for a rule which will
or it could be something more
it could be something very complicated
for example you could choose very
complex curves in high dimensions which
can kind of cherry pick the points if
you like
so this is the traditional machine
learning algorithm and this is what i
mean these kinds of images are more
associated to deep learning algorithms
where there are many parameters very
high degree polynomials
and they can
really learn arbitrary concepts so then
the nice thing about those learning
models is that they are universal in the
sense that they can learn any function
so in all of these choices
and this is just a subset of the choices
there can be issues
um
we already talked about societal
historic biases
uh what may happen you may say oh i'm
not using gender of a person so what's
the problem i mean these numbers are
fair no these numbers may not be fair
because you know as i said traditionally
women might have lesser education lesser
income so
these numbers might be tilted against
them
right and same about this right i mean
the the
the the labels and other
there can be many inaccuracies there can
be misrepresentations in your data set
you might have more men than women so
you don't learn much about women and so
on
and models of course can further
exacerbate bias in a very mathematical
sense that i'm going to omit but all of
these things
can very concretely lead to
issues
but you can see that you know these
choices that we are making we are making
these choices as humans
yes in the end we design an algorithm
which is a precise object but um but
these are the choices we are making
uh let me give you another example of of
of this
of this
of bias which is something other than
gender or race which we talk a lot about
something
which i mentioned earlier in terms of
polarization
and this is bias in a different space
it's in the space of opinions okay so
imagine
that this is you and this is
your
uh twitter or facebook feed
um so if you know let's say you log in
now
and between the last time you log in and
now
many many of the people who you follow
or
or are your friends would have generated
posts okay so this is the set of all
posts that facebook or twitter can
potentially show to you
and this is their key thing this is
their billion dollar algorithm the
content selection algorithm
which
from this views used setup set for each
individual
creates a personalized feed
and i have
chosen to represent again as a toy
example where the set of all documents
or set of all news articles instead of
all tweets are divided into two types
the red type and the blue type okay the
situation on the ground is more complex
of course but let's say this is the case
and this content selection algorithm
also gives you a very limited ability to
interact with your personalized feed so
you can say i like it or i don't like it
i mean for a very long time this is what
it was
and now you can do perhaps a little bit
more so this information the reason why
this information was so simple
uh
was kept so simple is because then the
signal reaching the content selection
algorithm was very clear
and so it could use
this
to show you the next
personalized next time when you come
to show a personalized feed again
so what is really happening
so what is really happening in this
in this content selection algorithm is
that for each individual user
it it
it it represents each individual user as
a point in some very high dimensional
space of opinions or articles
so there is this very high dimensional
space consisting of
all possible articles classified into
red and blue
and in the beginning
the algorithm has no opinion of you no
prior of you so you start off somewhere
in the middle
so when you start off your feed will
look
kind of
balanced
but then you click on something
so when you click on something the
algorithm thinks okay
this person seems to like this post and
the post is red
so let me let me change its
representation
uh a little bit towards red so and this
is a very precise movement that happens
in the space
uh i mean these dynamics uh are governed
by the uh you know the profit function
so you know what is the goal ultimately
the goal is that
the content selection algorithm should
show you feeds which you will keep uh
well you know which which you will keep
clicking on right and so that you don't
you don't go away
so you they do that so maybe now a new
feed is generated and maybe now you
click on a blue one
and so now you move a little bit to the
blue and so on so over a period of time
in a relatively short period of time
what happens is that
what we see happening is that two people
starting from very close to in the
center
uh
can diverge their opinions can diverge
and you know
what that really means is
that you kind of in from the algorithm's
point of view you move into the deep
blue or deep fret space
and
after that your feeds are basically
going to be just mostly blue or mostly
red i mean take all this with a pinch of
salt okay so this is this is
caricaturization of uh
of uh
what is really happening but it's pretty
close to what is happening
so
so what can we do uh
you know these kinds of biases are
emerging so what can we do
so we can focus on correcting data
uh we can talk about participatory
design of models
uh you know so we have to take into
account not only facebook or twitter's
preferences or google's preferences but
also preferences of the individuals
which has not been happening so far
we can
once we agree
on
the
joint goals or the joint models
we can try to design algorithms that are
now constrained
to be fair in some sense and
just like we have a police
and a legal system and a police system
which keeps auditing and
and doing things to control people
um
we have these
algorithms algorithm audit
units or or you know
companies or whatever
mostly civil u
you know
civic bodies
which are studying
the impact of algorithms
and users
um
so here there's a little problem though
that when i talk about fairness or bias
you know it's not just one thing
okay
it's uh
it's many things possibly right so
so when i say something is not fair it
doesn't it's not clear what it means it
may be clear to an individual who has
experiencing fairness but when we talk
about designing algorithms we need to be
precise what do we need
and
and what that really means is writing
down a precise metric a precise way to
measure
uh unfairness or bias
and
this picture which is still partial
kind of probably gives you a sense that
things are very complex the landscape of
fairness is very complex there are many
many different types of notions of
fairness that you can consider
at least 40 which have legal backing in
various contexts
and
in each context there are multiple
stakeholders
and you can prove theorems which say
that you cannot design algorithms which
are
uh which satisfy
multiple notions of fairness so
unfortunately you will have to fix the
context and in that context stick to a
definition or notion of fairness and
then say okay let's design
uh algorithms in that framework which
are
fair
so
this is where some of my work which i've
been doing over the last few years comes
in um
and
one of my main contributions is
to specify
a very
general framework
for users to encode their fairness
constraints so we saw that the landscape
of fairness constraints can be very
complex
and what we did was to kind of figure
out what's the simplest possible way for
for us to mathematically encode these
fairness constraints
um and then design algorithms which are
constrained to be fair
when you add constraints to a system uh
so this is an algorithm here which is
computing some function from data
the moment you constrain it a natural
question arises is that the previous
algorithm is not going to work
so
who will design this new algorithm and
whether it's even possible to design an
efficient algorithm so you know so
efficiency is the key word here because
you can
imagine having a
you can write down a function which you
would like to compute
but then if it's not efficiently
computable
it's not going to happen
in the sense that you know the size of
data and the size scale at which we are
operating is so huge
that we the problem should also come
with some efficient algorithms otherwise
uh you know you will have to pay some
computational price of fairness
on the other hand from the point of view
of let's say a company like twitter if
you say constrained twitter's feed right
so you give some controls to the user
and say the user will control to the
extent the content that they want to see
then twitter will object immediately and
say you know but now we don't know what
the engagement metrics will be and that
can really wipe us out from this market
so we're not going to agree to it so so
this is what you may think of as price
of fairness fairness is a great goal but
in this capitalistic society who pays
the price of fairness who will pay the
price of fairness so these are very
non-trivial and important questions
and my work has
addressed the whole pipeline
starting from identifying bias to
fixing data figuring out the right
models developing fair algorithms and
studying
impact
and
so not all
algorithms oops okay so maybe i skipped
a slide not at all algorithms are equal
some algorithms are very high stakes
uh
and some algorithm i mean you know for
example the algorithm used to schedule
the fleet of hertz car rental
perhaps has less impact on in you know
at a scale than
uh something like what you see in
twitter or facebook or something that
you see in google search or
or
classification algorithms or
um you know or
or or other stuff so so i've worked on
some of the high-stakes applications
and come up with interesting uh
solutions you can see more about them
many of these solutions actually come
with new demos once we designed the
algorithm we code it up we create a demo
for you to see
and you can if you're really curious you
can go to this website and play around
with it
so just to give just to wrap back and
say okay so what what does the picture
look like in this
world of personalization conceptually
it looks like the following that our
framework constrains the algorithm to
not let people
go beyond a certain point
i mean retrospect this seems very simple
but the hard part is in designing new
algorithms which respect these
constraints
so that's the
that's the main uh contribution of this
work
so so all of this was assuming
that we know
data we know that the data is accurate
and one of the key questions
once you start looking deeper into the
system one of the key questions
or key issues that we see
is that this data
may not be accurate
so besides
historical and societal biases there may
be other factors
which actually
uh
come into the way of data so let me now
explain that
and now we are going towards
understanding uh
bias in human decision making from
algorithmic decision making so we'll
make a transition and then i think in
next 10 to 15 minutes i should be able
to wrap up for 10 10 10 12 minutes
um
so
just so priya are we taking the
questions at the end or are or in the
middle
if you are open to um
i think this is a good good point to
pause for a minute and see if anybody
has questions about the previous uh part
i'm open yes
okay um i haven't seen anything appear
in the q a yet but we can encourage them
uh the only note that i have is that uh
you know christina's pointed out i mean
there are lots of people who are
interested actually would like to have
the links posted
okay yeah so uh
okay so okay so i'll keep on going and
and you know think about questions and
feel free to interrupt or ask any time i
mean i think it's
uh it's important actually uh if i may i
wanted to ask a quick question
so you know um
you know
it's really uh sort of remarkably clear
exposition uh nishite of how our sort of
inference systems are biased and how in
turn these results that are recovered
from these
and the claims whatever can change us
right so there's the sort of the power
of the algorithms that while they encode
our bias they may also hold the key to
mitigating bias right so they're very
sort of uh
they are sort of you know epistemically
they serve as sort of exposures right
they're very effective exposures of
human bias so one thing i was curious
was you know when you talked about
assigning scores for example we were
looking at it right so how much of the
bias really comes from the fact that you
know mathematical scores etc have an
implicit ordering right like 5 is better
than 10 or whatever yes but what if we
replace
at the top layer
you know i don't know i had sort of a
lame suggestion why not just have colors
or something you know something that you
can at a lower you know at a deeper
layer map into numbers yeah obviously
that's a great question so yes i mean i
think that's a very good question
and the answer to this is not entirely
obvious because as i i i already hinted
that you know you can design some
beautiful systems which are supposed to
do what they're supposed to do
but in the end you will also need an
algorithm to find the parameters of the
model yeah
so
much of this stuff is constrained by
that
aspect of things yeah so the reason to
go into this continuous space of ordered
numbers you know simplify everything the
real numbers not even discrete i mean
you can i mean in the world of discrete
numbers there is still more you can do
than in the world of continuous numbers
right
so the thing is that these algorithms
which optimize are essentially
algorithms which work in continuous
spaces
uh things like gradient descent gradient
flows i mean these are inspired again
from physics in some sense
and
and yeah i mean these these this is the
set we are working with so you know
if you face a problem today and you are
let's say you are an engineer who's
working in a company and whose manager
gives a task to design something you're
not in the position to reinvent an
algorithm
right
so you will just use off-the-shelf
algorithm and you will just encode but
you know you just do the minimum thing
you say okay let's just
encode everything as a real number and
ordered in some sense
without putting so much thought into
what impact your decisions have on the
lives of others
and this also has to do with a complete
failure of the education system in some
sense right i mean
i must say that i take responsibility
because you know we teach people
uh design of algorithms
data structures and so on but
you know a decade ago nobody nobody in
their lecture would even mention the
potential possibility of
uh
the impact that
the the choices will have
and and now i teach a course in which i
make people
at least be more aware of the
assumptions and their potential impacts
right we still do the same thing but we
just make them more aware
of the impact so i guess
just changing around the categories of
representation
is uh not enough a because the there are
too many algorithms lying around people
will just use them you have to
completely start with a new
set of categories but i guess the
ultimate limit as you said you know is
that we have a well-defined mathematical
space in which we live right
i mean but it's also a very challenging
question i mean you know how do you
capture a human i mean in what what i
mean you know
i mean
all said and done i mean if you want to
implement this on some kind of computer
then going back to turing's work i mean
during proof that this is uh i mean you
know any computer is equivalent to the
turing machine right so at some level
you will have to
encode
uh uh something as complex as human
uh
in let's say a binary form or some i
mean some using some represent some
representation right
so
that still remains the
uh yeah i mean there is a lot uh so so
there is a lot to say here and a lot to
do here yeah so by no means i'm
pretending that we have solved any
problem in fact in this part of my talk
i'm gonna tell you how we did not solve
that problem that we aim to solve
actually and the reason if i may
continue yeah please go ahead yeah
is is that so far i assumed that data so
all of these algorithms that we design
work
as long as the data
is
accurate so forget the issue that you
know women might have historically lower
salary than men
but
we do assume that the salary is what it
is being reported i mean you know that
the person is reporting the right salary
right
or we are measuring information
correctly
but
as we delve more into human generated
data it becomes even more clear
that the data that we record is
first of all
not
not necessarily uh close to the data
that we should record even if you want
to record somebody's ethnicity right
it's not clear that when we look at it
when we record it we do have that
person's facility
i mean it's it's like as a physicist you
would you can understand this probably
you know you can look i mean you you
wish you had the true data but you know
data traveling over billions of years
coming from very far they'll add some
noise and you know all kinds of things
might happen to that
so in in this context
what we have been seeing
is due to a variety of reasons
uh for instance you know often
we need ethnic information but we don't
have ethnic information because it may
be illegal to
uh have ethnic information to record
so what do we do we impute ethnic
information from other things
so that gives rise to a noisy estimate
of somebody's ethnic information
okay
maybe because of privacy concerns some
you might have to add noise to data
and what i want to focus on in this uh
in this uh rest of the talk uh uh in
just for 10 minutes is
implicit biases
so much of this data
also comes from certain applying certain
evaluation processes on individuals
so
for instance sat scores i mean we here
at yale are in the business of taking
decisions about students faculty
everybody all the time
we get
you know we want to recruit individuals
for
some vaguely specified goals
uh
but we choose metrics that's a sat score
this that and the other there is a whole
evaluation process and these evaluation
processes can have implicit biases
and the punch line is that much of the
stuff that i talked about this first
generation study of algorithmic bias
actually does not seem to work
well
when data is perturbed and alexander
madhuri who is an expert in designing
algorithms for perturbed data hopefully
will tell you more
about this on on on monday
so let me just talk about one type of
perturbation which is implicit biases
yeah and this was the punch line you
know it it can cause even if your
intention was to correct for fairness
if it failed to take into account the
precise way in which the data can be
perturbed the effects could be worse
than what you so the intervention could
be you know the cure can be worse than
the
the cause is that the right saying i
think so
um
no the effect could be the worse than
cure or something like that yeah
sorry i'm getting a bit tired
uh so implicit bias is uh is uh is
rampant in the real world
there is lots of evidence i am not
qualified to
to do these experiments but there are
uh very prominent uh you know economists
and sociologists who do this
and
in almost all aspects of our social
interactions we see
rampant implicit bias to just
give a give a example which is relevant
to us i think there were these studies
done where
emails were sent to ivy league
professors
uh the content of the email was exactly
the same
except in some emails the names was name
was changed from a male to a female to a
white sounding name to a black sounding
name and there were significant
differences
in the percentages of responses
now one can always argue
and and try to explain each individual
data point but when there are so many
people who study this and find
systematic issues uh one cannot deny
that there is something called implicit
bias
in this world which is really the
unconscious attribution of qualities or
lack thereof of members of particular
groups
so
the the the bottom line is that what you
observe the data that you observe may
not be accurate
so let's look at a very simple problem
uh
which now
starts moving from
a problem which you may not associate
necessarily to computer science but
nevertheless is still an algorithmic
problem and
many of us here might have actually
tried to solve this problem so the
problem is very simple again it's a toy
problem don't take any of this stuff too
seriously the whole the goal is to
explain the point
so suppose you have m individuals that's
100 individuals in this case one two
three four five six seven eight
individuals
and each individual has some latent
utility so this is the true utility of
an individual whatever it is
and i have
four interview spots
okay so i i have maybe one faculty spot
in my department but i want to shortlist
four people to interview
so what shall i do
as
you know as we have said one of the
reasons why we are encoding them as
numbers is that we can compare
so
the higher the number the better it is
so our goal is to
shortlist these four people or n people
which
maximize the cumulative rate and utility
so this is a very simple algorithm
actually which i think everybody here
you don't need to take an algorithms
class to design such an algorithm which
is to first find the one with the
maximum remove them from the set find
the next one remove them from the set
find the third one remove them from the
set find the fourth one
that's your set of four people that you
would like to
interview okay this is very simple even
a child can solve this problem
the
the issue with this
is
that it it assumes that these blue
numbers here that you see which are the
true utilities are the real ones that
you're seeing
okay
but in reality if we have
uh if we are suffering from implicit
bias
we might not see this
true utility
or latent utility
so here's a very simple
mathematical model of implicit bias
which is
suppose there is some parameter
beta you can think of beta as let's say
0.9 or in this case half
and for every person in a certain group
you view their utility to you
the observed utility
to yourself is half of the true utility
of course you don't know that you're not
doing this process
you know explicitly so this is my view
so i am let's say the person who can
observe
the entire
thing
uh so so you don't i mean you know as an
individual who's making this call you're
not aware of this beta
uh if you were then you would correct it
but you're not so you just view this
person as being useful to you to the
extent of five
units as opposed to 10 units
so now what would you do i mean what
would you do you would find you would
use the same algorithm again but with
the perturbed data set right so instead
of the true utility of this person being
18 now it's nine
so now when you go and select the top
four
instead of selecting the top four which
maximize your latent utility you
maximize the observed utility and these
are not the same numbers anymore
so this is a strange situation because
it's actually good for everybody if you
can see the truth
because you just don't know that this
person actually has higher utility for
you because of your biases your biases
are stopping you from doing this so what
can we do
one can do anti-bias training i mean
this is the traditional solution uh that
you can apply which has limited efficacy
um there's actually a very interesting
uh solution to to to a version of this
problem which is called the rooney rule
which has been used in the context of
the national football league here so the
rooney rule roughly says that
in the process of
selecting who to interview for a head
coach of an nfl team you must interview
at least one black person
if i get it correctly
and
there is evidence uh at least in the in
the media that this seems to be
a useful thing to do
so the question is is it really uh in
this simple problem does it really work
and if so to what extent
so what we did recently is to look at
the following
intervention
algorithm so so now
we say okay so so there's a new
parameter that we introduced l and we
say select at least l people from this
disadvantage group so even though you
don't know your implicit biases i can
still constrain you as a policy maker to
say that you must select at least let's
say two people from this
set of women to interview
and what we can show is that
you know you can
pick a value of l carefully
then once i fix this as a policy maker
then you
still doing what you're doing you still
doing whatever you're doing within
implicit biases
uh can recover
the right set
uh
so this might sound a bit
counterintuitive but there is a there is
a nice mathematical explanation for this
so we can come up with interesting
algorithmic interventions uh in in these
situations
one can also ask you know okay so it's
all seems to solve the problem locally
what about the long-term impact
so we can model this process as a
dynamical system
and also do experiments with people
and
um and
we can show
that
you know under a simple and well
established rule of how humans change
their opinions you know which is moral
through bayesian learning
the rooney rule over time significantly
impacts the implicit bias so we come up
with a new way
uh at least uh uh
you know i mean we we come up with a new
way as a suggestion
to
to do this kind of training against
implicit bias
anyway so if you're interested you can
look at some of our work on this stuff
i'm just going to end now because i
think i'm out of time
um
so what did we see in this talk uh
so one of the first things is that you
know human decisions
can appear
in this objective or seemingly objective
world
of algorithms
and make it make them biased
bias can mean very different things in
very different contexts and
sometimes it may be impossible to
satisfy all the constraints of bias in
in algorithmic situations and also
real-world situations
and there's a great demand uh to design
algorithms given the the rampantness of
these algorithms and the impact they
have already on society there's a great
movement going on
at least in certain communities
which is thinking about
redesigning some of these high-stakes
algorithms
to keep in mind the context and the
stakeholders
and finally
an understanding of algorithmic bias
can not only inform the design of fair
or unbiased artificial algorithms but if
you view
policy decisions as also algorithms
acting on populations
then it also gives us insights into how
to redesign policies
and uh some of our work
is
uh heading in that direction
um you can see more of of my work on
this website controlling bias
and
pre already mentioned you know this is
not an nda verb which only technical or
mathematical
uh prowess can lead you to good
solutions so here at yale we have a set
of a collective i like to think of
we call this computation and society
initiative a bunch of like-minded people
who come together to try to understand
how we can address these problems from a
multi-disciplinary point of view
and i would stop here and thank you for
your attention and priya it's all over
to you
thank you so much nishit this was
absolutely wonderful what a clear
exposition i think
as always you know every conversation
with you i i learn new things and i
think what you have clearly showed us is
you know epistemically algorithms
serve as very
effective exposures of bias
and that we can also in turn
use them as devices to mitigate the bias
in turn so they're sort of very very
powerful and useful at the same time so
i think we have one question in the q a
that i will read out and then
i of course have a couple of my own but
i will hold my horses for a little bit
so our first question is from one of our
regular attendees jenny hi jenny
and her question is instead of
constraining the maximum bias
a user can
arrive at could you also imagine other
ways to push the user away from their
biases for example showing other random
contents or even the opposite of what
they liked before
uh this could also stimulate new
interests i mean i guess she is
referring possibly to the polarization
example right right so i i think i
understand the question thank you for
reading it and thank you jenny for
asking this question
um
i i think that the in the picture it's
not the person that we are constraining
it's a representation of the person that
we are constraining and it's actually
exactly doing what you're suggesting in
some sense
so the constraint is on the information
that we are going to show this person
uh so
if so what effectively in in the most
simple sense what it translates to is
that let's say we we
you know twitter cannot show you
completely polarized content it has to
show you at least that's a 20 now this
20 percent is an arbitrary number but
let's say 20 content which may differ
from your current political view
and then the question arises how do you
choose this content
now
the the the real you know so we all know
through personal experience that if i if
you meet a random person with a
diametrically opposite political opinion
it's unlikely they will have any impact
on your political opinion
so we want to pick articles which are
the most likely to have an impact on you
so i mean in some sense to explain it to
colloquial language i mean if your
friend or your family try to explain
something to you
you might
be more swayed as opposed to a person
who you don't like a priory or who you
don't trust or who you don't know a
priori
right so the the task of selecting the
right articles or the right news content
is a very important one
and that's really where the fine
optimization goes in
so yeah that's what we do actually
great
thank you um
okay so i guess um
i have this other question actually
which was about the rooney rule um so
you know i'm
going to stray and use my own experience
as a guide right so isn't it true um and
i think you know this is echoed um more
generally is it isn't it true that when
you have one representative of a
disadvantaged group
amongst you know in that interview
example that you had
um that then they come to stand for
everything that that group represents
positive and negative so
that one person
could much more easily serve as a
trigger to our biases
but if you have two then there's a
little more noise right so you cannot um
um you you know you're 100 correct and
that's really what our result shows
so the parameter l that i talked about
is not one right
so yeah so i
that's right so i think the the question
uh that was raised in the literature was
well you know what can you show about
this uni rule and so we cannot show much
about
the l equal to one case
uh but we can show at least
mathematically we can show
uh
you know that if l is something a little
bit larger than one
then
it has yeah so it's i mean in some so i
think your intuition is 100 right that
the noise kind of cancels out right and
and then you start getting the signal uh
of the quality because from one sample
you know you might get something which
is pretty far off from the
the truth you know the true mean for
instance but if you have many samples uh
then you get a better idea of the group
yeah so so so thank you for asking this
question uh unfortunately we already
solved this and this is the okay i can
tell you more about i can tell you more
about it i'm glad yeah glad to hear that
yeah but you're right on track on this
one yes that l had to be um
greater than once it means you
completely understood what i said which
is
which is very flattering
so um other so i think there's a
question from talia
and the question is you describe the
context-specific nature of bias and
fairness
what are the implication of implications
of that context dependence for efforts
to develop more general ai are there
ways to reduce bias in the application
of relatively general ai tools that's a
great question yeah
um
yeah so this is a this is a very good
question but a very hard question as
well
i think uh
first of all i mean if i were to give a
talk on
ai
and machine learning i think
i would first start by
kind of
bringing it down to the level it
actually is that what the media portrays
it is so we are nowhere close to the
kind of stuff that you i mean you know
there are been successes
so i am not worried about right now
general ai and the
you know
but in a very specific context let's say
you design an algorithm
which potentially can be used in
multiple contexts then there has to be a
component there
which
somehow quickly recognizes or learns the
context and then
uh specializes itself
uh
to a well agreed upon notion of fairness
in that context now it cannot just
arbitrarily choose but i mean you know
so the the architects of the algorithm
right uh
uh
have to agree
a priori
you know for what context what notion of
fairness
or bias is important
and so that information has to be
included as a part of the algorithm
itself i don't know if it answered your
question uh but
um
we are very far from constructing any
such thing so
uh but yeah these these are uh these are
the big big questions
the frontiers hopefully in the next few
years
we will get to some of these
so
please go ahead and share and type your
questions um
sunishik while we are waiting for
someone else i'm gonna i'm gonna pipe in
again so you know um in physics we have
this intuition that
when you have uh when the central limit
theorem operates right so when you
marginalize over many many many
observations
you kind of get rid of the noise
i mean is
would i be right in saying that that
isn't quite true in the class yeah so so
that's a very precise mathematical
theorem we can i mean uh so that's thank
you for asking that question so what
does the central limit theorem say it
says the following suppose you have
random variables x1 to xn
right and you take their average
or take the sum and divide them by
square root n square root n is a
variance right let's say these are
uh gaussians i mean whatever these are
random variables with means they are not
correlated with each other not
correlated well yeah not correlated but
the important point is that you took n
and the function that you computed of
them which is the sum or rather the
let's say some sum divided by some
number
no particular
random variable has a very high
quote-unquote influence on this function
right so the reason why physics works is
that nature has i mean very rarely we'll
have functions
where
it is a function of many many variables
right but somehow a very small set of
variables uh dictate the outcome of the
uh
of the function so
but you know the kind of algorithms we
are talking about in this we are not
just doing
uh simple statistics calculation we are
optimizing we are picking the maximum
among let's say a set of gay people
or case scores or something very
brittle i would say
you know so there is a brittleness that
comes into it
and i think this is a this is a perfect
question for uh for our next
conversation on monday
because uh i mean the brittleness of
these algorithms is what alexander
martha studies
uh without worrying so much about bias
but you know about the brittleness and
one of the ways in which you can
kind of include your intuition from
physics in the design of these
algorithms is to smoothen these
functions out exactly i was going to and
smooth
these functions out so what are ways to
smoothen functions out i mean in
mathematics
there are many ways i mean there are
these operators you can take a function
and you want to compute its value at one
point
well you can take a small neighborhood
around you and just take the average
around this point so you know it's you
can do a short random walk or brownian
motion around this you know and then
take the expectation of the function so
there are various tricks in which you
can
smoothen the function out
and
smoothening helps carry through your
intuition
but what is not clear
is that this smoothening
will not very dramatically impact the
accuracy
yeah
so when you talk about uh
you know we are talking about trillion
dollar economies okay we are not this is
not a joke
of second decimal place in
drop in accuracy of something
means
many many many more dollars than i have
or huge consequences
right huge consequences
so convincing a company such as facebook
or google or whatever to move towards
algorithms which are less brittle
uh is currently an impossible task
right because you know and the only way
to do that is to first formulate a
regulation i mean you know
um you know without any regulation
uh which ties their hands somehow
you cannot
and and for that i mean this is really
the context of this talk what is the
purpose of this talk the purpose of this
talk is to
you know to give people influential
people who may not be experts in
algorithms but who have their influence
in various domains right
go and have a conversation about
algorithmic bias and the impact and then
you know
eventually gain the ability at the
at the highest levels of decision making
in this country and others
to to have the right conversation with
these tech companies to to hold and
twist their arms and say no you have to
do this because if you go and say you
know you do this when you know this is
not possible to do
right
yeah okay so i think so but yeah i think
you're yeah designing smooth algorithms
is uh is is what
will solve many problems actually not
just this problem yeah to be continued
on monday thank you so much nisha okay
so uh first of all uh there's a there's
a question uh from sean barrett sean is
on the faculty in the physics department
um very interesting talk thank you it's
interesting that the rooney rule with l
greater than one is seen as something
that could be effective theoretically
in the sports media recent coverage has
suggested that the rooney rule has not
been working since the numbers in 2020
are essentially the same as they were in
2003.
i think they might be using l equals one
but another issue is that the size of
the pool of all nfl coaches
is not that big
what l value l equals two perhaps made a
difference in your own model thank you
so excellent question uh sean
and a hard one uh so
i don't know much about uh nfl i must
say so i i will probably not be able to
address your question about nfl and why
the rudy rule isn't working anymore
it seemed like at some point when i
looked at
news articles they seem to suggest that
it is has some impact
and it also
was being used in other
settings uh corporate hiring and so on
um
but i think for reasons that were
mentioned by priya
so okay so first of all uh
our
our results hold under some assumptions
uh and those assumptions are that
people's
uh true utilities are distributed uh
according to some random variables
and that has a role to play in our
analysis
so if that assumption is not true our
result doesn't apply
first of all let me just say this up
front so and and so then the question so
maybe then that would suggest is that
the
the the samples that they are choosing
do not satisfy the assumptions of that
are required by our model because our
model does predict that will work
that's a possibility
and and sean i'll be happy to have any
uh conversation with you
each other
yeah
thanks nishit i see richard and barbara
um and i see them waving to say hello
yeah hi
hi
yeah they're still muted um
there we are
yeah
hey there we are
yeah lovely to see you both and um we
enjoyed it very much yeah
very very yeah very very um interesting
talk um
barbara any questions do you have any
questions finishing
richard
no we don't thank you
okay great um are there any other
questions ty do you see anybody else i
don't see any others thank you i think
we picked them all up okay great
so um uh thank you initiate for this uh
wonderful talk um
and uh for taking the time to come and
speak to us today and uh we look forward
to the conversation on monday to further
explore um these very sort of
profound truths that you have helped us
understand about algorithms what they
can do and they what they ought to do
and what they ought to do better than
they are currently doing so
i want to wish everyone a very good
thanksgiving break and a nice
thanksgiving celebration for those of
you who are
fortunate enough to have family
celebrations and are able to travel and
so on
um so i uh just wanted to mention that
our upcoming talk the next talk in this
uh series is going to be by kyle cranmer
uh in the infant series um he's a
physicist
particle physicist and he will be
talking about you'll be addressing the
issue issue of how do we look at very
large number of events at a collider
like cern and try to infer um laws make
discoveries and so on
and uh before
that talk we also have in addition one
of our distinguished
book series uh talks and
mapping as knowing series talk by uh
neuroscientist mariano sigmund and the
mapping is knowing series talk this is
mapping the brain and that is on
december 8th
so
at this point i just want to thank
everyone in particular tai
thank you so much tai for as always uh
helping make these events happen
and to guy for helping with the av and
to all of you for attending and last but
not least to nishid for speaking to us
thank you very much and good evening
yeah bye thank you i may just mention
the post talk conversation will be
taking place at five o'clock on monday a
bit of a departure from our usual time
of three so it'll be a 5 p.m our regular
attendees
might want to take note of that thank
you
thank you so much thai for that
announcement okay bye